- [Instructor] You've
already spent a lot of
your mathematical lives
talking about functions.
The basic idea is give a
valid input into a function,
so a member of that function's domain,
and then the function is going
to tell you for that input
what is going to be the
corresponding output.
And we call that
corresponding output f of x.
So, for example, there's many
ways of defining functions.
You could say something like
f of x is equal to x squared.
So that means that whatever x,
whatever you input into the function,
the output is going to
be that input squared.
You could have something
defined like this.
F of x is equal to
x squared
if x odd.
And you could say it's equal
to x to the third otherwise,
otherwise.
So if it's an odd integer,
it's an odd integer, you just square it.
But otherwise, for any other real number,
you take it to the third power.
This is a valid way of
defining a function.
What we're going to do in this
video is explore a new way
or potentially a new way for
you of defining a function.
And that's by using a definite integral,
but it's the same general idea.
So what we have graphed
here, this is the t-axis,
this is the y-axis, and we have
the graph of the function f,
or you could view this as the graph of
y is equal to
f of t.
Now, what I want to,
and this is another way of representing
what outputs you might
get for a given input.
Here, if t is one, f of t is five.
If t is four, f of t is three.
But I'm now going to define a new function
based on a definite integral of f of t.
Let's define our new function.
Let's say g,
let's call it g of x.
Let's make it equal to
the definite integral
from negative two
to x
of f of t
dt.
Now, pause this video,
really take a look at it.
This might look really fancy,
but what's happening here is,
given an input x, g of x
is going to be based on
what the definite integral
here would be for that x.
And so we can set up a little table here
to think about some potential values.
So let's say x, and let's
say g of x right over here.
So if x is one,
what is g of x going to be equal to?
All right, so g of one
is going to be equal to
the definite integral,
going from negative two.
Now x is going to be equal
to one in this situation.
That's what we're inputting
into the function.
So one is our upper bound of f of t dt.
And what is that equal to?
Well, that's going to be the area
under the curve and above the t-axis,
between t equals negative
two and t is equal to one.
So it's going to be this area here.
And we, since it's on a grid,
we can actually figure this out.
We can actually break
this up into two sections.
This rectangular section is
three wide and five high,
so it has an area of 15 square units.
And this little triangular section up here
is two wide and one high.
Two times one times one half,
area of a triangle, this
is going to be another one.
So that area is going to be equal to 16.
What if
x is equal to
two?
What is g of two going to be equal to?
Pause this video, and
try to figure that out.
Well, g of two is going to be
equal to the definite integral
from negative two, and now
our upper bound's going to be
our input into the function
to two, of f of t dt.
So that's going to be going from here,
all the way now to here.
And so it's the area we just calculated.
It's all of this stuff,
which we figured out was 16 square units,
plus another one, two, three,
four, five square units.
So 16 plus five, this is
going to be equal to 21.
So hopefully that helps,
and the key thing to appreciate
here is that we can define
valid functions by using
definite integrals.